all right let's get straight into it
what's good josh your boy ddg you're
watching gq
on the rocks
[Music]
this is my first piece
just say ddg very very heavy i paid 18
000
very very expensive at the time about
this in 2016.
come over here i barely wear this
because i'll be poking people
and i actually i stabbed myself a few
times with this so this is a very very
dangerous piece
i actually had i couldn't bring this in
the club once that's how dangerous this
piece is
it's very very very sharp but i wear it
for music videos
but this was 10k got from icebox i'm not
gonna lie i seen a little pump with him
all
but he had the ones that was like all
the way around his arm
and i was gonna get that and then i was
messing around with it and every time i
put my wrist down
it like stabs the the table or whatever
so i end up getting this one where
there's only
spikes at the bottom so it's more a
little more comfortable but
i barely wear it now
[Music]
my favorite piece that i got here
i would say i would have to say this one
i didn't like it at first let me be
honest with you
i didn't like it at first i thought it
was just a little too bulky but the more
did i wear it
i feel like i just got to style it a
certain way but i wanted to just give me
like a big circle piece
peter marco made this one so they got
pontiac at the top ddg in the middle
pontiac made ddg rep in the city okay
this was fifty thousand i you got
baguettes
in the middle right here the diamonds on
the side right here
got diamonds inside right here diamonds
everywhere so i fluttered out
rex i really only wear this in music
videos you probably never see me out in
public
with this on just because it shines a
lot it's doing too much
and i feel like this is more so like a
music video piece rather than something
that i wear every day
so you know i pick and choose what i
want to wear
[Music]
got this piece right here it's a ddg
squad
i love my fans not even my fans not my
fans i'm seeing fans cause i simplify
for the people that don't know me but my
family
my squad so i got this chain to
represent them
and i was been supposed to give it away
but i never gave it away but i spent 4k
got from icebox got baguettes in the
face
one of my special people gonna get
all right you can go over to this one
this piece right here
cool little choker chain got a little
spikes in it something different
craftsmanship paid 25 000 for it we're
gonna come over here
this is the big cuban i didn't ran
through a few cubans in my jury career
um i'm a cheap collector though i ain't
gonna lie like i'll be trading
it you know i like to keep my money if i
get bored or some jury
and i don't want to know mo i didn't
keep it i'm trading this and i had like
a
two different cubans and i was like i
got a white cuban and a rose cube and
why not just get one two tone
but this right here 45
super heavy i barely wear it but i
usually put it on this chain actually
let me do this
i got this chain specifically for this
but i also wear it by itself sometimes
this was actually
this is actually a necklace that i mean
the chain that i had
this was like a regular all-white chain
that i had and i cut it in half
and i turned it into a bracelet to see a
lot of these rappers will be out here
spending extra money for nothing
you know what i mean remember i told you
about that chain that i had that i
traded in i lied
i actually cut it in half and made two
braces i don't know where the other
brakes are that
but it looks fire you would have never
known unless i told you tennis change
you would think these
wouldn't cost a lot and i see a lot of
fake tennis chains
you know what i mean and it kind of
discredits how much i paid for this
and it kind of hit almost the same which
is very sad it makes me feel like i
should have bought the fake one but
i can't wear fake jewelry so that's why
i have to spend so much money
even back in the day when i didn't have
money like that i couldn't really wear
jury because
my neck would break out so i got this
right here
20k for this one tennis chain
pointers is crazy bang's in the light
definitely worth it this one right here
pay 15 plus diamonds are smaller
probably got finesse though y'all
comment below did i get finessed or what
i don't know
rose gold pinky ring i have probably
haven't read this in like five months or
something like that i spent five years
cool ring got diamonds all around around
the sides
come right here got this right here now
secret for y'all i got this some ice box
right cartier sells the same one
but they charge like 40 000 you know
what i mean for the same thing
i get i get nice diamonds and i get the
white gold
i spent 10. like this right here this is
my grill this is another
music video piece you'll never see me
wearing this is very very uncomfortable
i don't like wearing grills just for the
simple fact that you know uh
secret nobody knows this i haven't told
the world this i have veneers
nobody knows this i never told nobody
this but i have veneers so when i put
this on there
it's kind of uncomfortable you know what
i mean so i don't really like wearing it
but i'm wearing the music videos because
it's shining
[Music]
let's get into the watches the watches
is really my thing i'm really into
watches
and i've been through a few of them but
this is what i have here today
i got this rolex right here got a little
scratch in it
i don't really wear this one this is
kind of like a red face and match red if
i wear red just to add some
pizzazz to my outfit this was 35 this is
just a datejust it's a datejust rolex
it's more of like a startup rolex this
plane you can probably get it for like
8k
or something like that i don't know 10k
or something like that so
definitely up charge with the diamonds
but it's very very nice it shines and do
what i got to do
and if i wear red and it makes the
outfit pop
come over here we got
the paddock felipe this is one of my
favorite watches
all white paid 60 000 words
i bought this on just a random day i
always wanted to paddock i got all the
other name brand watches so i always
wanted one of these and they shining too
crazy in here because the light ain't
right but when i go outside
they blind people this is my most recent
purchase this is a royal oak
ap bus down raised bezel all around it i
just got this
uh it's the chronograph i don't really
know too much about it
or nothing like that but it costs eight
so that's a lot of money that i just
spent on this
let me go ahead and put this
put that on right yeah this is the big
boy i think i'm gonna get more into
these i'm gonna get some more like
you know popping watches i feel like
this is a man's watch
diamonds busting crazy 80k
i'm gonna come to the big bang this is
one of my dumbest purchases
but it's kind of smart at the same time
this watch
looks like a g-shock you know a lot of
people might look at this watch and be
like
yeah what is it if you look closely i
don't know if y'all got the zoom on it
see that little piece in there i don't
know what it is but i knew it cost a lot
that's all i know look at it i don't
know what these two lines mean i don't
know nothing about this watch but i do
know this
hope your zoom work on your zoom button
work on this part too
check in right here
you're right there get in the middle can
you read that
it's a limited edition you ready limited
edition
16 out of 100. it's only 100 of these
made in the world
i got one of them i don't know if i'm
supposed to show you that serial number
now i don't care
um but this is a richard mill johann
blake is the name of it it's only 100 of
them
and i got this one my mind said when i
got this watch was i wanted something
that's
not loud but if i run into bill gates
now if i run into a normal civilian they
don't know what i got on but if i run
into bill gates so i run into
anybody anybody with money anybody that
knows anything about richard mills
it's a statement you know what i mean it
starts a conversation about this why
strictly just to have conversations with
people that
i would like to talk to and i can learn
from so 185 000
is what i spent on this watch and it's
the less the least flashy one so
just like that man
i see other rappers i see they do a
collection
i take a little bit of notes but i'm
more of like a watch guy i'm more of
like
i want to get to the point where i'm not
wearing diamonds anymore but i'm just
doing this for now
as a 23 year old with millions of
dollars and i'm just going with the flow
you know
all right it's your boy ddg on the rocks
gq appreciate you tuning in
i'm out